quantum physics isn't well understood it
has a reputation even scientists get out
in front of public and say that it's
counter-intuitive and mystical so when
someone repeats that you're inclined to
believe it especially if you have a
problem where you've went to a doctor
and the doctor didn't help you now
you're inclined to distrust science and
so when someone comes along the Rogue
scientists that real doctors don't want
you to know about you feel compelled to
believe them I have the backing of this
miraculous super mysterious and complex
Theory it's way better people buy into
it
I'm very much looking forward to this
episode I have been for quite a while
since I heard about your book I feel
like the world of quantum physics is one
which is used by all manner of different
people to explain things that they
absolutely shouldn't be but why should
we listen to you as some sort of
judicial Assassin of quantum physics
what are your credentials who are you
well I'm an associate professor of
quantum physics at the University of
Technology Sydney in Australia
one of the one of the big places to do
Quantum technology research and
development
and I've been studying quantum physics
for 20 odd years now
you've also written 60 books on science
in one form or another
yeah I have quite a few most of them are
children's books so the latest one
probably shouldn't read the children
and
because of the place I had to sit in my
house for the people watching anyway
yeah because it's a lot about not for
children yeah okay to study quantum
physics so what are the different types
of quantum talking about
quantum physics there are ways in which
people misuse and abuse and
misappropriate it
what are the broad buckets of quantum
yeah so in in the book I go through the
major Concepts in quantum physics so
like buzzwords that you might have heard
superposition entanglement energy and I
they each have their own brand of
attached to them
the there's sort of The Good the Bad and
the Ugly the the the
ugly is when it comes to Quantum energy
which is associated with things like
Quantum healing which
suggest that people do things that are
unscientific and not medically sound in
lieu of of actual medical attention and
medical advice so that's very bad uh and
then there's like mundane things when
people
misinterpret say entanglement as some
spiritual connection between things that
are separated uh which you know if if
you're not waste if you're not stealing
people's money and you're not harming
people no big deal so there's a whole
kind of range from from yeah harmful to
just annoying and head scratching if
you're an expert
okay who are the biggest culprits of
quantum in your view you know
do you remember the FBI had that deck of
cards and there was like the Ace of
Spades was number one and so on and so
forth who would be in your deck of cards
yeah that's a good question in the book
I try not to give much attention to
specific instances because you know I
I'm afraid someone will go there and be
like oh yeah that that feels good to me
um I'm gonna go with that instead of the
difficult thankfully everyone everyone
watching this is way too rational for
that to be a concern so you have carte
blanche I think I think the probably the
most famous uh
example is is Deepak Chopra who's been
at it for a while he had a book called
Quantum healing uh going back ages but
that's you know that kind of stuff has
been debunked many times over but it
keeps keeps coming back right you know
someone will debunk it uh you kind of
disappear and then he'll discover like
YouTube and then he'll blow up again
because he has a new audience
um of people that didn't listen to the
debunking uh so yeah so I think he's
he's one of the worst examples I would
say just because he has such a such a
huge influence uh and a big platform
most of them they they're just they just
disappear almost as quickly as they
arrive you know if you've
hopefully not you didn't nobody's done
this but like if you actually kind of
click on a link that you shouldn't it
usually takes you down this path of you
know websites that look like you might
be able to put your credit card
information in but sometimes you can't
even do that like the websites don't
even work like you have to be right on
the ball if you want to
actually waste money because they just
happen so quickly Mia Quantum
fluctuations in the world of quantum
yeah yeah and then there's obviously
yeah YouTube videos it's endless right
are you familiar with um Gaia have you
heard of that
Gaia uh are like the the Hindu god it's
a streaming platform that's
reappropriated the name of a Hindu god
um and it's like Netflix but for sort of
spiritual woo stuff okay yeah I I fear
that you may have had an aneurysm if you
discovered this before you
um wrote your book but yeah man I mean
you know from what I know and from going
through your work it seems like Deepak
Chopra would probably be pretty high up
on the list didn't you do go on a show
or something or didn't you have an
interaction with him I went I went on uh
his one of his shows the one called the
Chopra well and that was for my my last
book so the last book was called where
did the universe come from and other
Cosmic questions it's kind of I referred
to it as my love letter to quantum
physics whereas the latest book Quantum
is my hate mail
um and it because it talks about how
quantum physics you know explains
everything we know about the Universe on
even on cosmological scales it it really
kind of connected with his point of view
and his audience uh I was really
surprised actually when when I spoke to
him I was totally expecting to have to
you know argue with him debunk his you
know nonsense but he he genuinely when
you talk to him one-on-one he's just a
really really insatiably curious person
who just wants to know everything right
and he has this internal mental model
and he's just extracting all this stuff
and he doesn't spend enough time to
actually go through it and dive deep and
so he's just at this superficial level
and that's a real problem I mean you
know if you've seen like the dunnings
crooner Krueger effects curve right he's
at like the the peak of you know
misunderstandings
Chasm of ignorance or something yeah
so he
you know he he says he says a lot of
stuff I think he believes some of it
genuinely
um and others it's just him just him
like he's he's you do something for so
long and you're just good at it and you
have no no choice but to do it and he's
really good at just spouting things that
sound profound but are but are basic
basically nonsense
um I don't know how
how I think it's you know he's sitting
there I don't know how harmful he is
anymore he's you know just an old dude
right
um who someone puts a camera in front of
him and he starts talking but the
movement around him I think is is you
know it it steamrolled it's Unstoppable
um and that's that's the really harmful
thing
one of the key terms that you're talking
about here is quantum energy and energy
medicine and Quantum healing and stuff
like that what are the claims that are
made by the people that talk about this
stuff
well there's this
idea that
um you know every yeah okay so some some
of it is like morally true you have to
distinguish between like colloquial
Notions of energy that we we all use
today right but you know we tell
children and you know all energy comes
from the sun and plants take in energy
from the Sun and that's where we get our
energy and if you don't eat then you'll
feel tired because you need energy right
these are all just like colloquial
definitions but there's technical
definitions as well and people people
often you know mix these up and they'll
say well I have my you know my everyday
notion of energy and then I read this
thing about quantum physics and and
energy the concept there and they feel
similar so that supports my
interpretation right which is not
grounded in science so with energy it's
that there's this uh you know latent
energy that's just spread out throughout
the Universe and you can somehow tap
into it if you uh you know you think
hard enough or you meditate or you pull
out your credit card and spend 20 bucks
or whatever
but that's not how energy works right
there's no uh there's no uh kind of
mystical source of of energy
scientifically it's measurable and
that's well how do you know how do you
know that there isn't Quantum energy
well I don't but the thing is well there
okay I I know that there is there is
there is quantum energy right I mean
that's sort of what what we study and
what we research and what I teach to to
students but it's not the same kind of
energy as this Mystical Force that
permeates the universe
how do I know well I think that's a
deeper deeper question I mean it's
somewhat a philosophical question like
what does it mean to know something
in science we have a very very clear
notion right if if you can measure
and perform repeatable experiments
and those experiments give similar or
the same results then we can say that we
we know something and we assign some
some
objective notion to that at least an
intersubjective notion that we we all
sort of come to agree that that
we're going to include that in our in
our mental model of reality
uh that's that yeah that's how it works
in science so and unless you can measure
it
and you can tell someone the procedure
by which you measured it and they can
repeat it
then it's not scientific but that
doesn't mean it's it's wrong it's just
probably useless right and when people
talk about energy healing they're not
just talking about
repurposing their kilojoules from a
Snickers this afternoon into somebody
else's body they're talking about
tapping into some sort of extra special
Quantum fields that gives them the
ability to go in and fix your past
trauma or your athlete's foot or your
your gluten intolerance or whatever it
is that you're dealing with
yeah exactly
um yeah that's right so if you can put
it put a number like kilojoules on it
um then it becomes measurable and and
then and then you can make predictions
and yeah say what
what you could do with it by can now
it's been connected to the rest rest of
the scientific you know Corpus and you
can start to make use of it
why is it the case that spirituality is
such a hotbed for so much of this stuff
it's like a quantum theory of the gaps
almost
yeah that's right
um we we do have a a desire to know that
as humans we we despise uncertainty uh
we want to have some idea that we we
have everything sorted out we you know
uh and
when there is when there is a gap in our
knowledge we have we just can't help but
but fill it and
really the the problem is it's sometimes
it's not fillable and so
you get people that come in and provide
yeah very attractive options to fill
these gaps
and
people maybe just don't have the time or
energy or or understanding to know when
yeah when they should use a proposed
solution or or not
but what is it about quantum physics
specifically do you think that's
allowing this speculation to be sucked
in
it
so that I think the the recipe is like
you have some some you start with some
problem you gave some examples athlete's
foot or you know trauma or whatever uh
and then someone comes along and says
you know that's a really really hard
problem right
and it's going to take some some
complicated
almost miraculous Solutions
I happen to have those right and don't
worry because you know I know quantum
physics and if you know anything about
quantum physics it's super complicated
and it has all this counterintuitive
stuff so don't worry about all that just
just know that I've talked to the
experts or I'm an expert myself and that
sort of uh you know
implicates the the person into accepting
this miraculous solution so I think
that's that's kind of the the Crux of
the problem right that quantum physics
isn't well well understood it has a
reputation you know even scientists get
get out in front of public and say that
it's counterintuitive and mystical and
and then so when someone repeats that
you're you're inclined to believe it and
if
especially if you have a problem where
you have feel like you've somehow
tested out sort of the scientific group
or the medical route like you've went to
a doctor and the doctor didn't help you
right didn't give you the right pills or
didn't give you a procedure to to fix
your problem now you you have you're
inclined to distrust science
um and so when someone comes along you
know the Rogue scientist that's uh that
real doctors don't want you to know
about
um then yeah you're kind of
you you feel compelled to to believe
them
um because they're they're somewhat
aligned with you right they say well I'm
against uh the status quo I'm against
convention and and I have the backing of
this miraculous super mysterious and
complex complex Theory so it's you know
it's it's way better and yeah people buy
into it
yeah there's a a number of
uh elements I think of quantum theory
that the sort of quantum world that
lends itself
um to charlatans and grift as being able
to insert themselves one of them being
the fact that it is uh not particularly
easy to understand even me who's done
episodes with Michio Kaku and Sean
Carroll and you know a ton a ton of
different physicists who are very very
highly acclaimed if someone asking me
over a cocktail party to explain what
quantum gravity is a quantum theory or
why we can't reconcile general
relativity with quantum gravity I can't
explain it I can't even begin to explain
it right and I've had hours and hours of
conversations about it so first off you
have a topic which is difficult for
people to get into that means that
someone can be a gatekeeper to knowledge
kind of in the same way that in the
Middle Ages the Bible was not translated
into the common language because that
meant that the priests and the clergyman
were the funnel through which your
communication with God could only occur
right you had to go through them it you
were beholden to them because it was the
only way that you could access this kind
of information and it kind of feels the
same way on top of that I do think that
I'm gonna guess that you would agree a
lot of the information that you find out
at the quantum level is very different
to what we experience up here at the big
sort of level there's all everything
kind of behaves in a very different way
it's almost like a different Universe
right it's not it's part of our universe
it's just really really really really
small but it is very it behaves in a
different way and that makes people
think oh well maybe because it behaves
in a different way there are some
degrees of freedom that allow me to
extract that type of
movement to momentum and energy out into
the real world and I can kind of insert
my own
Choose Your Own Adventure choose your
own energy healing thing into that World
um and when you have that it the
difficulty of being able to understand
the blurriness around what it is and
certain people that are able to posit
themselves as experts it is just a
breeding ground for people that are
charlatans and grifters my roommate Zach
calendar has this thing he calls the
charlatan Playbook
and diet is another one of these because
you know even the best dietitians on the
planet it's really hard to do the
interventions we don't particularly know
what's going on despite the fact that
everybody eats multiple times per day
and there's a ton of contested stuff
around it where do they insert
themselves right into diet because it's
this gay cap knowledge and it's kind of
hard to understand and you can sort of
wish it think it believe it and achieve
it
so I I understand why I think both
spirituality that attracts a particular
type of person some wishful thinking a
lot of placebo effect some of this sort
of spiritual woo language and quantum
theory the world of quantum physics
which is
like the scientific counterpart to that
with sufficient uh unknowns and degrees
of freedom that people can can make it
happen I can see how that would be a
marriage made in Hell perhaps
yeah Quantum avocados no I think that's
a very uh
yeah you know you hit on some really
good points uh um I totally agree that
uh and so but I guess you know sometimes
public
engagement you know scientific
communicators do act really as The
Gatekeepers of knowledge and I think
some of them enjoy that enjoy being in
that position rather than you know maybe
they set out to say I'm gonna
educate the world on on my particular
topic of interest and then and then they
quickly you know buy into the fame right
and become sort of the gurus and you
know I can imagine you know it feels
good you know when people are luring
masks yeah being the being the the
gatekeeper of this knowledge
it's alluring
yeah uh or I mean I haven't made it that
for that far yet so uh I I'm still I'm
waiting for the I'm waiting for the
quantum energy healing that doctors
don't really want you to know about
pivot for Chris Ferry
um so one of the other terms that
a lot of people listening will have
heard about will have been vibrational
frequencies
what do you think people mean or what do
you think people think they mean when
they talk about vibrational frequencies
uh yeah well let me let me just point
out that uh just so that like there's
like a clear demarcation right so energy
the conventional concept or everyday
notion of energy is that it includes the
the idea that it it flows right it's
continuous
um what Quantum brings to the table is
that that's not that's not true at the
most fundamental level of understanding
we have energy comes in discrete chunks
so energy is not like a slide that you
can go up and down it's like steps you
have to be on a step these steps are
incredibly tiny you'd never notice them
in everyday life but they're there right
so that sort of the difference between
Quantum and classical energy that that's
never actually used in any of the
right they don't actually use
the real kind of concept of energy
but frequency is similar so again
we kind of understand that the how
energy is mediated between things is
through waves so there's electromagnetic
waves that we're using right now to
communicate over the Internet uh there
is sound waves that come from the
speaker in in your headset or or on the
speakers on your device
that's a vibrating air molecules that's
traveling as a wave so waves carry
energy
now
in order for that energy to be received
that thing has to resonate so we again
it's just another one of these words
that is has many meanings right there's
colloquial meanings and there's
technical meanings
um
it they're very similar So when you say
something resonates it's like you're in
tune with it but technically it's when
the wave that could potentially interact
with the thing is around the same size
as as the object so if you think about
waterways I think is an excellent
example so imagine you know you're
you're a boat and there are just in
there's an enormous swell in in the
middle of the ocean you wouldn't even
notice right like you look around and it
looks like
it's pretty flat around where you are
because this you know you can't see the
next the next peak in the wave
and if there's tiny ripples you wouldn't
notice those as well when do you notice
a wave if you're a boat it's when the
distance between the Peaks is about the
same size as the boat right so that one
end of the boat is at the top and the
other end of the boat has gone to the
bottom so
when things are around the same size as
the way that's when there's there's an
interaction and that that's when you
quote unquote resonate with it
uh so there's yeah exam just sort of
look around you and there's examples
everywhere like that's why we can't hear
microwaves right or we can't we can't
see radio waves
yeah so that that they your eyes
basically tuned to only the visible
portion of this fast electromagnetic
spectrum that includes radio waves
infrared microwaves and then the other
ends higher energy waves like
ultraviolet X-rays and gamma rays
they're all they're all hitting you all
the time right but you can't you can
only see the the visible ones and that's
just an accident of evolution because it
seemed to be useful uh for survival
now
so people think that they can somehow
I guess in in the implicit assumption is
that they can change change something
about their themselves what they think
or what they do so that they can tune to
some wave that's out there
and well that's just somewhat ridiculous
I mean it's it's true in like a
you know a sort of mundane sense right
if I if I uncover my ears then I've
allowed my hearing apparatus and all the
stuff that goes on inside my ear and my
brain to be in tune with those waves or
if I open my eyes I can be in in tune
with visible light but I there's nothing
I can do
to see infrared light unless you know
unless you trust scientists and
engineers and use technology then you
then of course you can but
um you you like we're pretty limited uh
when we think about the biology of these
bodies that we're carrying around
so when people say vibrational
frequencies
what they're probably talking about is
their emotional state how they're
receiving other people's emotional
states what they're putting out into the
universe and how that's impacting
field the quantum field perhaps
yeah so so you
you do have oh you do have like several
wavelengths associated with you and
different parts of your body again like
your retina is associated with a certain
wavelength that's tuned to visible light
your eardrum is associated with
wavelengths of sound you know uh but 15
Hertz up to however you know whatever it
is 44 000 Hertz
um and your entire body can act like an
antenna as well which is tuned to
roughly 10 Hertz so if if someone was
blasting a speaker that was 10 Hertz and
you know if you've been to concerts
maybe you kind of can can feel this
right really really low bass some of
which you can't hear with your ears but
you can feel in your body that's because
you are you are an antenna and certain
parts of your body will resonate with
electromagnetic frequencies as well and
those are you know regulated by the SEC
sometimes because it's unhealthy but
most of the time just because it you
know if if human bodies are absorbing
the signal then you're not going to be
able to get signal to your smartphone so
don't use those frequencies right like
Engineers don't think of humans as
things that they don't want to harm they
think of things that are in the way of
their Wi-Fi signals
the
if
now there there is there is this notion
that like if um you know if we agree on
something or we have the same opinion
then somehow we are in tune but you know
that opinion resonates with me uh which
is you know it's a it's a fine way to
communicate in in it works because it
it's embedded within a system of
language that we all understand and we
can make use of
but it it has its limitations and if you
if you start to say that it does things
Beyond just
you know helping social interactions and
people come to agreements then
then you're in trouble because you know
those those things aren't verifiable
and by this we're talking about someone
genuinely having a physical connection
between themselves and somebody else
that them and the other interlocutor are
moving or or attached through some kind
of quantum wave or Quantum energy field
in a strange way
yeah that's right so that if if that
were true then you should be able to
measure it right uh and if if you can't
measure it then you can't verify it so
it's it's just magical thinking
otherwise but how much quantum physics
can we measure is is it possible in your
view as somebody who has spent an
awfully long time studying quantum
physics that this could be something
that exists or is the only way that this
exists if it is tapping into something
which is outside of the field of quantum
physics most likely
it so you could take this point of view
right that that everything in the world
is it is just atoms right you know
nowadays we teach this to children or at
least I do
um that
all of this stuff around us including
your body is made of atoms and the world
is just a one everything you see is
built up of several of 118 elements that
we often see arranged on the periodic
table
that's it that's all there is to the
universe it's everything is just a bunch
of these atoms stuck together in
different arrangements and their their
interactions are mediated by
electromagnetic waves
so
with that understanding
there are there are things that are just
ruled out so I I can't
I I can't have a physical interaction
with you I mean again it's it's somewhat
subtle right because
in some sense I I can influence you
right if I pause for long enough then
you'll probably say something
um and that's
happening at a distance
but
so it really depends on the kind of
claim that you want to make right it
usually
they're they're quite they seemingly
miraculous things and and you know you
you apply a simple a simple rule right
if it sounds too good to be true then it
probably is so if if it sounds too good
to be true then it it it's not part of
Science and not part of quantum physics
quantum physics
is used to explain this this idea of the
world that everything is made of these
fundamental building blocks and what we
see around us is it's just a built up of
many many interactions of many of these
things and
we you know we understand that to an
extent that our entire modern world is
built on on quantum physics everything
around you you know the the device
you're using the the scans you get when
you go to when you go see the doctor uh
compact this if anyone remembers those
you know lasers
uh clocks GPS the internet computers
everything is is built from this
understanding that the world is made of
atoms
and if we put these together in various
ways then we can put that to good use
I was on about party talking to a girl
that was part of another group that had
turned up and she seemed perfectly nice
and was explaining about her young son
and what she hoped for him in the future
and the job that she's doing and all of
the rest of it and I was asking about
how she'd uh like changed she made some
job changes recently I think and she
said yeah I uh I just really started
raising my frequency and I thought well
now I'm interested and I asked what do
you mean when you say that
and she said well you know I I sort of
changed the way that I thought and I I
adjusted my emotions and I said yeah
okay but what about what about the
frequency thing he says well you know
emotions have got a frequency they
vibrated a frequency
I was like okay what do you mean by that
he said well
they
they vibrate you know because they
vibrated a frequency and I changed and I
was like right but what do you mean by
that and I kept on asking the what
question and it resulted in her saying
the sentence I believe in quantum
physics
oh
like
this was some like a a waldorf Gardener
castle that she could Retreat into that
would explain
something that I didn't understand but
self-evidently neither did she
um
I believe in quantum physics and uh she
did leave not long after this I think
that I was very polite I didn't like I
don't know take the piss but I didn't
push a good bit to say what do you mean
I raised my frequency what do you mean
emotions have a frequency and they
vibrate at a frequency and what do you
mean I believe in quantum physics like
genuinely for the love of God what the
do you mean I know I I don't think
I don't think that
she really knew and I think this kind of
TAPS into
what you're talking about with the The
Good the Bad and the Ugly of quantum
physics and also maybe even Deepak
Chopra as somebody who from the outside
might seem
willfully negligent or or kind of like
jovially uh ignorant purposefully
ignorant in a way that benefits perhaps
himself
but it can start people down a slippery
slope toward believing in things that
become increasingly and more and more
disempowering and less and less accurate
uh to the world around them
and
it can also cause people to do things
like abandon their cancer treatment in
place of going to do crystal healing and
stuff I'm pretty sure that uh wasn't it
um Steve Jobs who decided to try and do
some very holistic sort of woo things to
try and cure his was it pancreatic
cancer incredibly treatable 90 its
recovery rate had he have just decided
to go and get standard treatment from
Western medicine uh and he went to and
somewhere in Tibet or or India or
something and in a cave and had some
treatment and you know we lost one of
the greatest marketers and product
inventors of ever
because of that which shows that it
doesn't really matter how smart you are
that these kinds of ideas I don't know
how Quantum me Steve Jobs's worldview
was
um but these ideas can take a hold of
people and it is a very slippery slope
you know the if the thin end of the
wedge is just believing in entanglement
and two people that love each other have
an emotional connection that transcends
space-time and physics as we know it
it is just a difference of degree all
the way down to I don't need
chemotherapy because I've got some tiger
stones at home
yeah no that's right I mean we like to
say okay that's innocent or whatever but
the the
issue is that again people want simple
stories right and they're once they have
a story that they're comfortable with
that they stick with it the as as
scientists
this is just our
basic state you know we in order to make
progress you need some some assumptions
right but we're always ready to abandon
those assumptions when they lead us
astray
so
if if you accept some set of assumption
some story
then you're eventually going to be led
down that down the wrong path
if you need to have every new piece of
evidence or new piece of information fit
within that story
and you know you extreme examples are
like conspiracy theories like flat
earthers right
um so in order to believe that the Earth
is flat and then be told that people
live in Australia in order to make those
two things like fit together right you
have to say like we're all actors right
and you know we're in Hollywood and
there isn't really a place called
Australia
um
I mean some of us don't even have
Australian accents uh but
that that I think is is the problem
right that I I'm I'm fine with people
making assumptions and having simple
stories I do it all the time even within
a scientific context
but
you have to be ready to abandon them
when those those analogies those stories
no longer are fit for purpose
you had a quote in the book from Quantum
love
and you said when you use the power of
the quantum field honing your emotions
and intentions to create the frequency
or vibration of that desire you will
draw the things you want to you
yeah now that doesn't doesn't work what
the does that mean
uh that's yeah that's an interesting
book I think probably one of the my
favorite examples of quantum
because the person who wrote that book
Dr Laura Berman I think she's Oprah's
love expert a relationship expert or
something and it has a PhD from New York
University uh in what
probably sociology
that's right dude the pivot the seamless
pivot from sociology into
quantum physics is so Brazen I work so
hard to gain millimeters every
single year in self-confidence and then
there are people that decide to abandon
social science and just dip into quantum
theory like fair play do you know what I
mean fair play to it well I think yeah I
mean if that's allowed then then I can I
can give people relationship advice why
not all right
but so she in her book actually if you
read like the first chapter it's her
explanation of quantum physics which you
know reads like something that would be
in you know Scientific American or some
Popular Science magazine it's
it's it's not accurate but it's no less
accurate than than what you would see
from even a science journalist and then
the problems start to arise is when she
tries to connect that to her particular
area of expertise
um
but yeah I mean all relationship advice
is the same it's just has different sort
of layers of slapped on it
and she decided what you know there's a
there's a gap throw a quantum physics in
there make it quantum Quantum love
but that yeah that the then when you
make a claim like that one that you just
read out that is a very specific claim
which is
it's comically untrue I didn't mean I
I don't know
again they're all all of these cognitive
biases that come in right so if I say
okay well I read the book and I did the
sort of exercises that she suggested and
and then uh you know I played I played
the lotto and I won 20 bucks so it must
have been it must have been that right
so there's confirmation bias happening
all the time because the other 100
tickets that you play didn't win
um so yeah
yeah again it's you know this is these
huge gaps and all of these cognitive
biases that people aren't aware of that
that allow these things to thrive well
there's also a placebo effect which is
unbelievably strong right and I'm kind
of torn and this is more an ethical
question but
the placebo effect or the expectation
effect is David Robson would call it
which kind of expands it out from taking
substances to to expectations too that
we have around the world is the most
reliable effect in all of pharmacology
or medicine right if you could bottle it
you would have a Panacea and you know
they've shown that studies where people
take sugar pills that they've been told
are sugar pills have better outcomes
than people that don't and they've been
told that it's a Placebo so you
know I I I I
um disregard the expectation effect as
little as I can I think that it it is
very very useful
but
the mechanism that this thing is working
on is not what's being claimed the
outcome can be something which is
positive in the direction of what you
wanted to occur but the mechanism that
you set it up operated on is not
accurate and
is is
conning people or duping people or lying
to people or convincing them that a
particular thing works worth the outcome
because the only way that that outcome
can be achieved is by getting them to
believe it which means that you need to
give them a sufficiently convincing lie
I'm not sure and I'm definitely not sure
when there is a slippery slope down
toward believing things which stop you
gaining some of the benefits of
expectation effect and actually start
causing you to believe a whole host of
other silly woo
yeah
I guess the the
the issue I think is that there's a huge
gray area right there is there is no
truth right we have we have models of
reality
we have these these simple stories that
tell cause and effect relationships of
change of events but but these but these
aren't
true in any universal sense of of the
word there is no universal truth there
there's a big gray area and when you
think about it that way you can start to
see okay well there there are things
that are more truthy and things that
that are clearly untrue but even the our
best theories uh are are just useful
theories they're they're not true
theories so our understanding of how the
placebo effect works probably has
something to do with with uh you know
human psychology and potentially we can
get down to uh you know chemical
yeah chemicals that that are being
passed around within our body
and at some point you can say well you
know those chemicals are made of
molecules which are made of so you know
it's all yeah at some point it's all can
be understood as being based on quantum
physics
but I think you have to have these
different layers of explanation and
accept that at any point none of them
are true in any objective sense of the
word
they're useful so I think we should
accept
these lies if they if they give give us
mileage but as soon as they stop
giving us a return for believing it then
we should abandon it
so if you want to say well
you know this placebo effect works
because uh you know there's some some
Quantum interactions that are happening
in the brain and if you think the right
way you can make those align
and that achieves the outcome that you
want the person gets gets better
that's great but maybe maybe everything
should just have an implicit disclaimer
like your mileage may vary if you if you
use this model to do something else
it probably won't work
the problem that you have there is that
stopping people at the bounds of this is
what it's good for and it's not good for
much else or it's good for a small
number of things isn't the way that
human brains work you know if we if we
find success and and win 20 quid because
we did our right energy Crystal healing
and tapped into the con the quantum
realm I mean that's going to fix
everything like my chronic flatulence is
fixed by it my erectile dysfunction is
fixed by it like everything do you know
what I mean
um
moving on to another very common
question around quantum physics
uncertainty the uncertainty principle
what are people getting wrong about
Schrodinger and his cat and and and
uncertainty and all the rest of it
yeah so this one's that I would say is
one of the probably more mild ones so uh
nobody's it's just such a an abstract
concept that I don't think it's made its
way into into these other uh these these
other places no one's found a way to
monetize it yet is what you're saying
yeah yeah so uncertainty it's it's kind
of the Hallmark of quantum physics uh so
and there's this famous story that how
it was discovered by Werner Heisenberg
who had hay fever so he secluded himself
on this island
and it came to him in like in a dream or
something like that he woke up one
morning and had to write something down
and
you know it wasn't like oh he just you
know wrote it down in a stone tablet and
then brought it back to
Copenhagen it was more uh you know he
had this idea scribble it down then he
developed it over over you know probably
weeks to months and it was probably some
mess when it started but eventually you
know we retell the story as as it was
like this Eureka moment where he
basically had this idea
of trying to measure the property of
something so he there's this idea of
Heisenberg's microscope so if you know
how a microscope Works a light
microscope you shine light on something
light bounces off of it and then you
know gets magnified and enters your eye
then he thought well what if the thing I
was trying to to look at with the
microscope was a single a single atom or
a single electron the fundamental
subatomic particle
well when I shine light on it which is
fundamentally other particles it's like
two billiard balls hitting each other so
just the simple fact of trying to
measure something
Alters it in in some way so if I shine
the light on the electron yeah it's
going to bounce off and then come and
hit my eye and then I can infer
something about where it was in other
properties of it but now I've imparted
something onto that electron and it's
going to take off in some other
direction some random direction that I
don't know so that so his notion was
you can't simultaneously know where
something is and how fast and where it's
going at the same time you can choose to
measure one property but you can't
obtain everything there is to know about
both properties
nowadays we understand the concept A a
bit more subtly
the the real Crux of the issue is that
these properties aren't even defined but
it it doesn't make sense to say that
there is something pre-existing in the
world and our job as observed as
observers is to go and figure out what
those properties were that were there
regardless of whether we chose to go and
measure them or not so you can choose to
measure by setting up some apparatus
measured position of of something find
out where it is
but by doing so by arranging that
apparatus you've caused something else
about it to be undefined
so there isn't some set a pre-existing
set of properties in the world now this
gets sort of caricatured as
um yeah you when you measure something
you affect it and so you see this a lot
in popular culture there's another a
related effect in Psychology called the
Hawthorne effect or the observer effect
which is like if I prime someone before
I ask them questions then the responses
will be different than had I not found
them so if uh if like when you do these
psychological studies like if you know
the context of the study then you're not
going to act in a natural way right so
this is basically why you should take
every psychological study with a grain
of salt because
you know people aren't going to Act
Naturally when they're set in a in a
white room with one chair and asked to
do a task right that's not their natural
state they know they're being observed
so they're going to behave behave
differently and this sounds similar like
it has uses a similar set of words and a
similar set of Concepts but it's
unrelated like the the effect in
Psychology has nothing to do with with
the affecting quantum physics they just
seem similar
yeah there is a Associated phenomenon
that people talk about a lot I guess
which is quantum entanglement the
ability of something to travel faster
than the speed of light and then this
kind of gets stretched out to talk about
connection to the cosmos because we're
becoming Quantum entangled with somebody
else through love and spiritual
connection and stuff like that what is
and is not about quantum
entanglement
yeah that's a tough one because it's
probably the most uh abstract and
concept in quantum physics
at its base is if you try to understand
quantum physics from the point of view
of information
um maybe more of an engineering uh point
of view then a lot of these things
become clear
again the the issue in quantum physics
is that it at the same time it tells us
that there there is no fundamental
reality there is no thing out there
that's independent of us waiting for us
to come and observe it
but in order to make progress as humans
with our limited you know mental
capabilities we have to create these
sort of concrete
stories of reality
but you know as soon as you do that
you've violated the one principle of
quantum physics so we we do this as
physicists as well because you know it's
difficult to carry around all of these
abstract conceptual Concepts it's much
easier to just have some concrete
physical model in mind and then apply
our Notions to that
so with entanglement you know the basic
idea is say you have two two particles
and you interact them in some way and
then you separate them and if you've
done it in a clever way then the the
state of those particles is is some
specials to state that we call entangled
and and what that means is if I measure
a property of one and I get some outcome
which is random I'll I'll get the same
outcome on on the other one and it seems
like because I can choose which
measurement to do on one side that I
have somehow influenced the other one
and you'll see this in
repeated by scientists and you know in
science magazines and uh there was a
recent article even in the New York
Times that
quoted a scientist that said exactly
this entanglement is when things
particles are separated and doing one
thing in instantaneously affects the
other one but that's not at all what
what happens
this is this is you know the all of
these problems that we've been talking
about repeated but by scientists once
you've committed to this story of
there's physical things in the world and
and then you have this other this other
piece of information all that you know
they seem to be correlated in every
possible way I can choose then you're
forced to say something instantaneous
happened but that's just not true
there's there's no there's no influence
there's no information nothing is
traveling faster than light now
everything is connected right so there
gravity is is a simple example right
um gravity has no no bound right it the
force of gravity drops off the further
two objects get move away from each
other but there is a force of gravity
between you and the moon and you in the
Sun and you and all of the planets and
all of the stars right it's just
imperceptibly small
and
that but that that the connection say
it's between those two is mediated by
you know Einstein's field
but it can't travel faster than light so
there's no sense in which those things
can influence me
on any time scale that's relevant to me
I can shoot a laser and you know it it
it it it will take a few seconds to to
hit the Moon and back
and if I go further and further away it
just it just takes longer so yes
you know in some real technical sense
everything in the universe is connected
and probably everything it has some
small amount of entanglement if you try
to model it with quantum physics but
that doesn't actually help you do
anything
anything that was is relevant on human
scales but in time or in space
how much truth is there in people
talking about using quantum entanglement
to be able to communicate in the future
across galaxies while we could use we
could entangle these two things and then
we'll spread them apart and then that
means that we can communicate is there a
future in which you think that could
happen
no you I mean we're always limited by by
the speed of light so you
if I
take if I entangle two particles take
one two
Alpha Centauri or something and
then
you know I've done it in a very clever
way use all of our Advanced engineering
future technology whatever
what it means is they're just correlated
right it's like
photocopying a book right
um but not knowing what's in it and you
separate those two books
what do you know you know that when you
oh when those books are opened they're
going to have the same words in them but
you you know you can't use that to
communicate faster than light in order
to do anything with it some some more
communication would would happen now the
correlation is useful you can use these
correlations and in some sense
there's a there's a
everything about our our experience is
ultimately about correlations
like this conversation deals with
correlations like we we have a
correlated
dictionary of English right so that when
I speak these words they have a meaning
to you because there's this prior
correlation that has been set up but
just because that correlation was there
doesn't mean we could have
said everything that needed to be said
without actually having the conversation
right so
everything will be limited by the speed
of light and entanglement is just a new
kind of correlation that we can we can
create in the world and it can allow us
to do things more efficiently
But ultimately nothing nothing
miraculous
any sense that two humans can become
entangled together
um
no so
the
Quantum I think the way I like to think
about quantum physics is it's a theory
about isolation
so when you have an object and you
completely isolate it from its
environment
then
if you use anything but quantum physics
to describe that object and when I say
describe I mean make predictions about
the outcomes of experiments that you
might do
then you'll be wrong you need to use
quantum physics to to describe that
object if it's isolated from its
environment
now if you think about okay well
um you know the atoms in my body aren't
isolated you know why can I stick it in
an MRI machine or something and quantum
physics somehow
is the is what's power in that
technology it's that
if you if you've heard anything about
atoms it's that they are mostly empty
space so maybe you've heard this idea
that the chair you're sitting on is
mostly empty space and when you sit on
the chair you're not even touching the
chair there's you know an enormous
amount of space at least some you know
small enough scale between you and the
chair nothing ever touches right and and
the parts of the atoms
uh there's you know vast orders of
magnitude and scale
between the size of the parts of the
atoms like protons neutrons and
electrons
and the actual space between them so
basically everything is everything is
empty space
um
so the uh that's why quantum physics
is useful to describe those things
because in some sense they're isolated
from the other things around them
now
if you want to have something as big as
a human body to be usefully explained by
quantum physics you would have to
isolate it and well that means no No
Light No Air uh and it would cease to be
a human pretty quickly so
yeah you could you could get a large
massive object or two of them and and
have them entangled but it would be
nearly impossible to isolate them from
their environment and that's the real
issue like the bigger the object is the
more ways it can interact with stuff
around it and so you have to remove all
of those possible ways in order for it
to start to behave in a way that's
different from our everyday our everyday
experience of the world and I think you
know the largest thing that we could
probably get to be entangled might be
like a a future computer chip right that
would this would be the basis of quantum
Computing technology
but it even then the the apparatus that
you have to stick around it in order to
isolate it from its environment would be
huge so the places that they put these
things so if you've ever seen a picture
of a quantum computer it looks like uh
it I mean it looks like a giant tube
right uh an enormous sort of cylindrical
that and what that is is a dilution
refrigerator and a liquid helium
is used to cool the inside of that thing
down to
thousandths of a degree above absolute
zero which is which is that you know
thousands of times colder than even
outer space so we've created the most
extreme environment in the entire
universe here on Earth
just so that we can
you know watch watch an atom uh do
something you mentioned Quantum
Computing you also do a ton of stuff to
do with computer science but supposedly
on the cusp of a Quantum Computing age
and if we get there it's going to break
all of the algorithms because everything
that we've used to do credentials and
and security for cryptography is going
to be out the window what can and can't
Quantum Computing do
yeah well Quantum we don't know I mean
the a great quote from I think like the
late 1940s from the then CTO of IBM was
there never be a market in the world for
more than six computers
so clearly
um you know even someone of that caliber
can't make accurate predictions about
future technology
uh so I mean I can say a few things but
uh the disclaimers I don't know and
nobody knows what what this will be
useful for you know the first
application of a transistor was for a
hearing aid right and now we carry
around a billion of them in our pocket
um the
we have algorithms so these are like
you know recipes
if you can if you can transform this
this data into this data then you can
you can solve some problem one of them
is factoring numbers
and this is what you'd have to do to
break current encryption systems that
that secure the internet
but that I don't think that would be a
big problem for when Going Quantum
Computing happens and you we can already
see certain uh people with with
really important Secrets like state
governments and large corporations that
are moving to what's called post Quantum
cryptography different encryption
schemes that quantum computers we think
won't be able to break so if you say
you have to you have to ask yourself
well how you know how important is my
secret and important is is how long do I
need to keep it right so you can't keep
a secret forever maybe you need to keep
it for 50 years and then if you say
well if someone learned this in 50 years
time that would be bad and then you say
well quantum computers might be around
in 50 years then I should probably
switch but if you're like you know I
just I you know I don't care if people
know this next year if someone if
someone leaks my nudes in 20 years time
that's totally yeah you don't care yeah
so you don't you don't have to worry
right now you can you can keep using uh
iCloud or whatever right yeah that's
fine but if you think that's that's
really important maybe you maybe you
want to switch or
um you know send some customer feedback
to to Apple asking them to switch
the
but that's so yeah you know we say
quantum computers will break the
internet but probably not most likely
not people will you know people are in
the process of switching to post Quantum
cryptography and when quantum computers
become ubiquitous then we just will use
something different
um the other thing I think the kind of
the thing that you should keep in mind
you know the back of your mind I mean
think about future technology is that
um it it happens slowly right like
you know even think about probably the
most transformative
uh example would be something like chat
GPT where it had the fastest adoption of
of any technology yet it doesn't it
hasn't broken the way the world works
right like we still basically interact
and engage with the world the same way
we did before and the same will be true
of quantum technology it will happen
over a longer time scale but it won't be
like okay one day you just throw out
your old computer and now you have a
quantum computer in your house now it'd
be it'll be slowly integrated and the
end user won't have a different
experience because that would be
terrible right you at the end of the day
it's all driven by uh the economy and
the the customers right and what they
want and what what they'll buy
you know Henry Ford could crawl out of
the grave and step into a Tesla and
happily drive it away the interface
hasn't changed even though the entire
technology behind it is different
so with quantum computers you know if
you're just an average consumer and
you're like oh what I care about is you
know can will I still be able to use
tick tock then yeah of course right
because we wouldn't develop technology
that you know can't can't be used in the
exact same way and and sold to the same
set of people
the the other like promising future
prospects of quantum technology include
things uh like Quantum simulations and
that sounds like just more complicated
and and uh annoyingly complex but it's
incredibly important so when we design
new materials when we design new when we
design new drugs and when we want to
understand
how things are made we we want to
understand them at the deepest and most
fundamental level possible
so that that is basically at the level
of atoms like if I could understand
uh what sort of atoms I need to put
together to make a super strong material
or to make a material that can conduct
electricity without dissipation or
resistance then then I could you know
there's no there's no limit to the
imagination at that point right like
just yeah for example imagine you could
make a uh a material called the
superconductor that works uh at high
temperatures
and so these are the things that make
like levitating trains and and maybe
you've seen the levitating frog on
YouTube
um
if you could create a material that can
conduct electricity with with absolutely
no resistance then you wouldn't have to
build you know coal-fired smoke plants
right next to cities right you could
just throw a whole bunch of solar panels
out in the middle of the desert and the
entire world would have free electricity
why can't we do that well because it's
nearly impossible for us to simulate
using conventional technology
what happens when we put even just a few
atoms together but the number of degrees
of freedom and the amount of data that
we'd have to track is is just impossible
for even today's super Computing
clusters which you know still attempt to
do this like you know a huge fraction of
the world's energy budget is just
simulating interactions so that we can
make better fertilizer right
um if you could could create a computer
that just natively does this without
having to to attempt to encode all of
this information in a in a really
inefficient way which is what we seem to
have to do with conventional computers
then yeah then then you have all of
these sort of dream applications but we
don't know exactly
how we would do that with a quantum
computer we have you know the basic
fundamental idea and some simple
examples
and some understanding of what it would
be what would be required but
you know if someone dropped a quantum
computer on my lap it's not like I would
be able to get going on this right away
so the progress again will be slow we'll
see we'll see incremental improvements
uh but you know maybe 30 years down the
line it'll and if you look back and say
okay compare now to 30 years ago you'll
say it's a huge you know it's an
enormous change what about many worlds
are we part of a Multiverse is the fact
that I decided to say many worlds
instead of multiple worlds meant that
we've branched off into a different
universe as well now
Quantum this sort of quantum metaphysics
Quantum philosophy
um it's an interesting place it's a very
interesting place because it's like it's
like woo but
but it's people with phds so it's kind
of like uh it's a really it's a really
strange thing so I think it just goes to
show that yeah there's no matter how
much you learn how no matter how
educated you are you can still just get
attached to to things that are are not
to me comically comically miraculous so
I don't know but there's no it's an
interpretation of of quantum physics
so you have this idea of superposition
and then the cartoon explanation is like
things can be in two two states at once
but when you go to measure them only one
one of them occurs
so you mentioned earlier Schrodinger's
cat so that's like a famous example of
you put the cat you put a cat in a box
and inside the Box there's a vial of
poison and a hammer which breaks the
vial but the hammer is will only fall if
some Quantum event happens
so you arrange for that event to be in
superposition uh you know an atom
decayed or not decayed at the same time
so that means the hammer has broken the
vial or not broken the vial at the same
time which means the cat is alive and
dead at the same time but
you whenever you you
attempted to perform this thought
experiment and open the box you'd either
find an alive cat or a dead cat
okay so then the many worlds
interpretation says well uh there's a
Multiverse and in one branch of the
Multiverse there's an alive cat in the
one branch there's there's a dead cat
and you as an observer are on one of
these branches
and it's not testable
um and it it's not
it doesn't simplify anything I mean it I
think
for most people it's it's alluring
because it gives you this
yeah it gives you the sense that
um
that you know do that that you could
have you could have done things
differently or that they're
um you know there are better better
options that you could take right
there's another there's another version
of me that you know
it was more successful or didn't didn't
have health problems and I think this
idea that you know you could go back and
change things
uh
it's just something that people kind of
yeah people like but it's
there's no it's not it's not based on
on anything that's measurable like you
can't test to test test the many worlds
hypothesis
it removes the pressure of having to
make decisions as well because if the
decision that you make now whether it be
going left or going right is just one of
a number and it almost creates this uh
like liminal
excuse this kind of get out of jail free
card that you have uh which I understand
you know it's psychologically comforting
to not be beholden to being locked into
the future by whatever decisions you
make now and I understand there's parts
of me that really understands uh is it
agrophobia that's why people sometimes
don't like to leave the house I think I
I kind of get that I almost get the you
know or the the concern around germs and
stuff like that like that there's just
so many things that could happen that
are outside of my control and and if I
don't make any sort of decision or
commitment or if I try and change things
as little as possible I try and make as
few changes as possible to whatever
state I'm in now that would suggest that
I'm going to stay safe moving forward
it's a fundamental fear of the unknown
the unexpected the uncertain the future
but I understand I understand that why
that's psychologically disquieting
um but again with the many worlds thing
if it's
if the quantum physicist says it's
untestable and therefore
difficult for us to work out whether or
not it's true
I don't know I you know you can allow
people to indulge in it as a a sort of
psychologically comforting fantasy so
the person who developed it uh his name
is uh Hugh Everett III
um which is the worst uh
three generations of Heroes
he had a terrible life
um people didn't take his ideas
seriously
um
and he he had this he also developed
this notion of quantum suicide which was
basically that
there is there you know
like think about Quantum Russian
Roulette right you know
in sixth of the world there's six worlds
in only one of which I'm dead in right
and and five of which I live so you know
why not play the game because I'll
survive in one of them so if you
you know imagine this this sort of
thought experiment right like someone
says I you know flip a coin heads I give
you a million dollars tails you die then
you should play you should if you
believe the many worlds you should play
the game right because
in one of the worlds you're a million
dollars richer and then the other one
you don't care
uh so I think it sounds innocuous but
you know I think if you really took it
to its logical conclusion you you'd have
you'd be forced to
to also believe some pretty ridiculous
things and that's that's basically my
problem with it
I've heard you use the term not even
wrong
I would never come from yeah I'd never
heard that before uh can you explain
what that is for the people that are
uninducted yeah I recently was told it
it goes back to Paulie which is a
Quantum physicist but there's a book by
that title and it is basically about
well the book was written about these
ideas in theoretical physics that are
just not testable right so they're you
can't even say that they're wrong so
it's it's just a mental masturbation
essentially that you you come up with
all these ideas and theories and they
you know you can say well because they
have mathematical symmetry they're
beautiful therefore they must be true
things like that but you know a
practical person would come along and
say uh I can't tell you not to believe
that because it's not even testable and
you know the mental state that you've
put put yourself in is difficult to get
out of uh so yeah you're it's not even
wrong I can't even say it's wrong it's
what is it it's nothing right
yeah that's um
that's maybe one of the most like not
kind of patronizing but like
good insults or pushbacks that I can
think of when someone starts spouting
out a lot of horseshit you mentioned uh
previously that you wrote a book in the
past that was a love letter to physics
and quantum physics and this is your
hate mail did I see on your Twitter that
you've been receiving genuine hate mail
from some people that are a part of the
spiritual community that took a little
bit of upset at what you've been pushing
yeah I slip it off to be honest it's the
recommendation I give in the book is to
just not engage there's there's no
really no no good can come out of it
unless you're prepared to put in the
time and it takes a lot of time so what
have people been accusing you of
well
it's
I mean they
you know everything you can imagine like
I've lost my way I need to find Jesus
you know
yeah like religious stuff to
um
to like they have their pet Theory and
that you know they'll accuse me that I
don't really understand quantum physics
because yeah and then they'll just
repeat something that's again not even
wrong and it's not even worth it's not
even worth my time to engage because it
would be like the conversation that you
had with with that woman that
they they would just repeat themselves
or go in circles
that conversation actually took an awful
lot away from it but yeah man I I think
as somebody that is uh world-class
expert at receiving comments from the
internet uh my my theory is absolutely
just engage where you want to uh and
draw the line at that like if you want
to find out I wanted to find out from
that girl and it was a very enjoyable
and and respectful conversation and I
wanted to find out what do you mean when
you say raise your frequency what do you
mean when you say I believe in quantum
physics what do you mean what do you
mean that was perfectly enjoyable it
wasn't cantankerous at all or anything
else
but the line on the Internet is just
don't feed the trolls unless you want to
unless you've got some spare food lying
around and some specialty that you want
to throw at them I have friends Destiny
this guy's he's a streamer and he lives
he absolutely breeds for
uh
opposition and and for
um
antagonism and for debate and stuff like
that and that's his lifeblood I've it's
like he's a a plant and that's the sun
um whereas for me and perhaps for you
too there are that's not what how I
would enjoy spending my
Saturday afternoon so I would choose to
do other things and I I every time that
I see some of my smart friends on the
internet getting into spats with people
um and I understand in some regards if
you use it to kind of make an example to
signal boost a bad idea and show how
easily it can be fixed that's not
necessarily a bad way to do things but
one-on-one in the DMS or in a a message
thread or a a thread on Twitter or
whatever trying to slowly chip away at
some person's world view it's like look
I've done I've done the work I've
broadcasted my stuff in a video or in a
book or a presentation or whatever
and if you disagree with that that's
fine but I don't know what you think my
time or your time or anybody else's time
is worth but I can promise you that it
is worth way way more than trying to
convince somebody that doesn't like me
and doesn't agree with my worldview that
they're in the wrong
right
yeah
um yeah don't don't feed the trolls I
think it's it's good advice it it will
often have the opposite effect that then
you expect catalyze you catalyze the
trolls rather than yeah yeah unless
you're prepared to put in the time like
I you know if you have a a family member
that believes in some conspiracy then
you then maybe you want to slowly
you know kind of remove that remove
those those those beliefs but it
probably takes
you know the problem is like it takes
orders of magnitude more time to fix
than it does to create it take me a
second to create on the
internet
and and then the damage is almost
irreparable because even if all of the
scientists in the world went to to
debunk that
well I could I now I could just create
10 more pieces of in the time
that took them yeah have you have you
heard of brandolini's law which is what
you're describing though
brandolini's law also known as the
asymmetry principle it takes a
lot more energy to refute than
to produce it hence the world is full of
unrefuted
yeah exactly there's a lot a law for
everything including the production of
on the internet Dr Chris Ferry
ladies and gentlemen if people want to
keep up to date with the stuff that you
do and check out some of your work why
should you go
so the website is
csferry.com and there you can contact me
you can follow me on on all the social
media platforms though uh I tend not to
use them very often but uh yeah a bit
secret but you can contact me via my
website if you want
or uh follow me on apparently you can
follow people even on Amazon now so you
can follow me on Amazon oh yeah Chris I
appreciate you thank you for today
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace